hi just a quick one today because I've
got a lot of other stuff going on right
now more on that later hopefully this is
a follow-up to the previous video about
avoiding negative side effects Link in
the dobly doo so uh watch that first if
you haven't yet I wanted to talk about
another possible problem you might have
with low impact or impact regularizing
agents uh one I forgot to mention in the
last video some people definitely
mentioned some things close to this in
the comments if you got this good job
feel free to brag about it the problem I
want to talk about is avoiding positive
side effects so before we talked about
how most side effects are negative
rather than having to figure out how to
avoid negative side effects maybe it's a
more tractable problem to just avoid all
side effects but if you look at the side
effects of for example getting me a cup
of tea that includes effects like me
being happy or me not being thirsty or
me feeling more awake because I've had
some caffeine in other words every
reason I wanted a cup of tea in the
first place if the robot can think of a
way of getting me a cup of tea that
still results in me being thirsty Y and
tired just as though I hadn't had a cup
of tea it will prefer that option now I
can't off the top of my head think of
any way to do that assuming we've
defined what a cup of tea is well enough
so maybe the robot will conclude that
these positive side effects are
unavoidable just like how using up a tea
bag isn't unavoidable side effect but
it's not great that it's looking for
ways to negate the benefits of its work
and again the more intelligent a system
becomes the more it's going to be able
to figure out ways to do that or how
about this we've set up our system to
try to keep the outcomes close to what
it predicts would happen if the robot
just sat there and did nothing at all
right what actually would happen if it
just sat there and did nothing instead
of getting me a cup of tea one thing is
I would probably become confused and
maybe annoyed and I would try to debug
it and figure out why it wasn't working
so our robot may want to try and find a
course of action such that it does get
me a cup of tea but still leaves me
confused and annoyed and trying to debug
it and figure out why it's not working
because that would have been the outcome
of the saf policy how do we deal with
that issue and all of this is assuming
that we can come up with an impact
metric or a distance metric between
World states that properly captures our
intuitions there are a whole bunch of
difficulties there but that's a topic
for another video so that's it for now
uh next time I think we'll keep talking
about the paper concrete problems in AI
safety and look at some other approaches
to avoiding negative side effects so be
sure to click on the Bell if you want to
be notified when that comes out oh and
if you think this stuff is interesting
and you're at a place in your life where
you're thinking about your career uh the
careers advice organization 80,000 hours
has just put up a really good guide to
careers and AI safety I'll put a link to
that in the description as well highly
recommended checking that out especially
if you don't think you're technical
enough to directly work on the research
uh there are a lot of different ways you
might want to get involved oh and let me
know in the comments if you'd like me to
make some videos about AI safety careers
you know if that's uh something you'd
want to see
[Music]
and to end the video a quick thank you
to my patreon supporters that's all of
these excellent people right here um I
especially want to thank yonatan R
represented here by this sock his choice
not mine anyway thank you so much for
your support uh I hope to have some more
behind the-scenes stuff going up on
patreon this weekend if I can I hope you
like it